okay everybody it's time for drew's news
it's a bird it's a plane no
it's true's news
and with me at the death
is my super news man it's rossi ross
matthews
we're so excited because we have got an
incredible
person human and woman at the desk today
i've actually known her since we were
kids and it's an honor to have her here
in person live her new movie a castle
for christmas is right on time for the
holidays take a look
i should probably tell you
that bedroom mail act where the fifth
duke died i made that up
just wanted you to have the worst room
i know
the fifth duke died in the battle of
clawden
the six was thrown from a horse and the
eleventh your father died alone
in a hotel room in london hi
ugh not again
[Applause]
this is so exciting
and this is
this is not the first time you've been
here no
so last time to this day i tell brooke
how i'm doing and like that oh my god
i'm doing so good i'm so happy to report
everything's going well i don't need to
report i don't
like them and we collaborate and we make
fun plans and then um we'll do segments
where we eat donuts together oh yeah
up and be like brooke will you come and
eat donuts like on the show and then
she'll call me and be like will you do
the movie i'm doing right now and i'll
be like yes what can i do like where we
we
when we did
the movie together here we shot it right
here and we had never acted together i
know
it's like so weird i know right you've
known each other forever that was the
first time
it was really it was nice to sort of
after all these years kind of bring it
all together and for something like a
wonderful project which is you know i
mean a castle for christmas is like
right up my alley i am the place that's
the trailer i'm in the movie i've i got
to do scenes with you i'm obsessed the
trailer it looks so good
it's got everything that you need in a
christmas movie yeah and there's dogs
there's pubs there's horses there's
knitting knitting whiskey
whiskey
terry always of the princess bride
literally shot in scotland i lived in
the carriage house of an actual
neighboring castle i like how there's
neighboring castles and it's a happy
feel-good movie i think we just need to
be entertained yes it's in the in the
christmas spirit thank you
holidays um i have to bring this up
last time you were here with drew you
guys were eating donuts and today you're
here with cookie week
and you brought us your favorite cookie
i did what is it i love peanut butter
and i love chocolate so the fact that
they're all in one cookie makes me very
happy walk me for starters can we talk
about the girl pounds of this cookie
look how thick this is you guys look at
that
that's that's a big size of my hair
so it's chocolate with peanut butter
chips in it yeah
this works and it's fun to smile after
you've had it oh yeah i was gonna stay
here
oh thank you
that's a good friend
that's what friends do
well
are you guys ready for some headlines
[Applause]
we're gonna kick it and stay on this
holiday theme because tis the season
for christmas music and yahoo life
reports it's not for everyone that's
right a consumer reports survey found 23
percent of people dread holiday music
say what i know psychologists say for
some it can be a real trigger reminding
them of all the gifts they've got to buy
and relatives they have to see soon and
oh gosh the holidays
so on the other hand
some people can't get enough of it and
they wish it would play year-round
rossi brooke i don't know about a
year-round holiday music i don't know
about year round well listen i am what
they call hojo to the max all right i am
holly jolly and unapologetic about it
okay so sign me up but to your point
when they start playing it like on
october 15th i'm like girl no that come
on it's too much right
it makes me melancholy it doesn't make
me like angry or i'm not you know upset
but it just makes me melancholy i don't
know why it just sort of makes me like
oh remembering when i was a kid and you
know what i mean like that i think it
does evoke some of that i don't i don't
hate it no i do appreciate that i know
every word to every holiday song and so
i sing so loud in the car you guys know
you sing so loud in the car too you know
it um i love the vince geraldi peanuts
music and i really like when people like
there's a band called she and him with
zoe deschanel um and it's like i love
when people make christmas music i feel
like more
musicians and bands like tony bennett
and lady gaga like make christmas music
like let's do this every year
all right you know we have been enjoying
the romance rumors swirling around we've
been talking about it here kim k and
pete davidson you know you're obsessed
so are we or at least curious well we
just learned something new about pete's
relationship rules entertainment tonight
reports he just revealed his number one
dating deal breaker listen to this he
says if you're rude to a waiter or a
server you're not getting a second date
how about that oh i know now
to me this seems like like normal kind
human being if you were on a first date
with somebody and they were like
snapping at the wait stop i wouldn't
make it through the meal we're not
getting dessert i'm not even getting to
the appetizers
would you like be able to like get up
and leave and just be like i'm sorry
like now i could now in this day and age
my age yes because life is too short and
it
should not be spent in the company of
people who aren't good human beings to
other people this makes me love him that
he couldn't be more right anyone's real
it's real it's a real thing
it's them yeah well you know we think
that they're they're dating we think
they're having fun they're having fun
they had pajamas on they had matching
pajamas on did you see that picture with
what it was
kim who else is there chris and um
flava flav i think was in the picture
with them oh i love flavor flavor yeah
since remember that like liza minnelli
wedding where like michael jackson oh
dude david what's his name
well i was at the elizabeth taylor one
and that was
only as like
with michael jackson and yeah two you
went with michael jackson too
yes to the wedding
and and because
michael had to walk her down the aisle
to the elizabeth to the elizabeth you
went i had to dance with larry for
tinsky because technically i was the
mother of the bride
technically she broke shield is trying
to break me oh my god
that is an amazing story i was like you
can't do this to me please don't do this
to me i was like she doesn't even want
me at her wedding what dish of course
she did well i mean we weren't like
friends and then
then then the first dance came and
michael danced with elizabeth and i was
like oh god no
i was like let's do this this is good
dancing oh my gosh i feel like i want to
do one can i do another story
okay get away take it away i want to go
like this okay
next up we're going to talk about the
latest chugi casualty
yes through i know that you've talked
about chugi at the news desk it's the
word that kids are using these days to
mean uncool
out of style or just basic
so the new york post reports that
generation z says that blonde hair is
officially choogy
they point to young fashion mavens like
gigi hadid haley bieber and florence pew
and they say they've all gone from
blonde to brunette recently so what do
you guys think about this do you think
about being i thought blondes had more
fun i wasn't sure i love blonde hair i
don't think it's chooky whatsoever
blonde hair is stunning striking
beautiful this report is chugi
exactly
well said
[Music]